>>> AS WASHINGTON DEBATES HOW
BEST TO HANDLE BORDER SECURITY
AND IMMIGRATION, THOSE ISSUES
PRESENT REAL-LIFE CHALLENGES TO
PEOPLE WHO LIVE ALONG THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE TOHONO
O'ODHAM NATION NATION.
THEIR RESERVATION STRETCHES
ACROSS 2.7 MILLION ACRES OF THE
SONORAN DESERT.
BUT MEMBERS OF THE TRIBE LIVE ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER.
AS LILIA LUCIANO LEARNED, THEY
OFTEN FIND THEMSELVES CAUGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE BATTLE BETWEEN
DRUG SMUGGLERS AND U.S. BORDER
PATROL.
>> Reporter: AN HOUR AWAY FROM
TUCSON, ARIZONA, AND ANOTHER TWO
TRAVELING THROUGH THE UNPAVED
ROADS OF THE SONORAN DESERT
TOWARD THE BORDER, WE ARRIVED AT
THE FIRST BUILDING STRUCTURE FOR
MILES.
WE'RE IN TOHONO O'ODHAM NATION
ABOUT FOUR MILES FROM THE BORDER
WITH MEXICO VISITING FRANCINE.
SHE'S LIVED HERE ALL OF HER
LIFE, AND SHE FREQUENTLY
RECEIVES MIGRANTS, TRAFFICKERS,
AND BORDER PATROL ALL COMING
THROUGH HER PROPERTY.
FRANCINE JOSE SAYS EVERY FEW
DAYS SHE FINDS PEOPLE ON HER
PROPERTY ON THEIR WAY INTO THE
UNITED STATES FROM MEXICO.
>> THE OTHER DAY WAS SOMEONE
CAME AND THEY WERE --
>> Reporter: USUALLY HOW LONG
HAVE THEY BEEN IN THE DESERT?
>> THE LADY THAT CAME SAID SHE
WAS OUT THERE FOR THREE DAYS.
>> Reporter: SHE GIVES THEM FOOD
AND WATER, WHATEVER SHE CAN
OFFER.
CAN YOU AFFORD IT?
>> NOT SO MUCH.
>> Reporter: FRANCINE KNOWS HER
GENEROSITY HAS TO BE LIMITED.
SHE SAYS SHE'S OFTEN QUESTIONED
BY AGENTS ROAMING AND
SURVEILLING THE AREA EVEN ON HER
OWN PROPERTY.
>> I JUST ALWAYS FEEL LIKE I'M
THE TARGET, AND YET I'M ALWAYS
OUT HERE.
>> Reporter: THIS YEAR ALONE,
BORDER PATROL IN THE TUCSON
SECTOR HAS DETAINED THOUSANDS OF
MIGRANTS WITHIN THE RESERVATION.
THE EXTREME HEAT OF THE SONORAN
DESERT CAN BE FATAL FOR MIGRANTS
TRYING TO CROSS.
LAST YEAR WAS THE DEADLIEST ON
RECORD IN THIS REGION.
IT'S NOT JUST MIGRANTS.
AGENTS ARE ALSO CHASING DRUGS.
>> YOU CAN DEFINITELY SMELL IT.
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: FRANCINE SHOWED US
THE BAG OF MARIJUANA SHE FOUND
THE NIGHT BEFORE.
WE WERE THERE WHEN A BORDER
PATROL AGENT ARRIVED TO PICK IT
UP.
>> SHE COULD BE PROSECUTED FOR
HAVING AN ILLEGAL SUBSTANCE ON
HER PROPERTY.
SHE COULD BE CRIMINALIZED IN
THAT.
>> Reporter: HAS THAT HAPPENED?
>> IT'S HAPPENED TO MANY PEOPLE.
WE END UP BEING THE BAD GUYS.
WE END UP BEING INTERROGATED
WHEN WE'RE JUST TRYING TO HELP
THE CAUSE.
>> Reporter: VERLON JOSE IS
FRANCINE'S COUSIN AND THE FORMER
VICE CHAIRMAN OF TOHONO O'ODHAM
NATION.
HE SAYS THE COMMUNITIES EXIST
BETWEEN A TUG-OF-WAR AND CRIME
GROUPS TRAFFICKING PEOPLE,
DRUGS, MONEY, AND WEAPONS
THROUGH THEIR LAND AND THE
MILITARIZED ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT WORK TO STOP THEM.
YOU THINK HE'S FOLLOWING
SOMEONE?
WHILE ON THE RESERVATION, WE SAW
BORDER PATROL HELICOPTERS
HOVERING ABOVE.
EVEN WITH THEIR CONSTANT
PRESENCE, TOHONO O'ODHAM NATION
POLICE SPENT MOST OF THEIR TIME
DEALING WITH BORDER ENFORCEMENT
ISSUES.
THE TOHONO O'ODHAM NATION
EXTENDS 60 MILES OF THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.
BUT FOR THEM, THEIR NATION,
THEIR COUNTRY IS ON BOTH SIDES.
THERE IS NO SUCH DIVISION.
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE IS A
BARRIER THAT IS MORE
ENVIRONMENTAL THAN A WALL WHICH
THEY SUCCESSFULLY STOPPED FROM
BUILDING.
AND THE BUILDING OF THE WALL ALL
ALONG THE ARIZONA BORDER EAST
AND WEST OF THE RESERVATION
FUNNEL ELSE TRAFFICKING RIGHT
THROUGH THE TOHONO O'ODHAM
NATION.
FOR VERLON, A WALL HAS NEVER
BEEN THE ANSWER.
HOW DOES IMMIGRATION POLICY
IMPACT THAT MIGRATION FROM YOUR
POINT OF VIEW HERE?
>> I'VE ALWAYS SAID THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN.
NUMBER ONE, AMERICA NEEDS TO
KICK ITS DRUG HABIT.
NUMBER TWO, THERE HAS TO BE TRUE
IMMIGRATION REFORM TO ALLOW
THOSE THAT WISH TO COME HERE TO
WORK AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
ECONOMY OF THE AMERICA, YOU
KNOW, AND THEN OF COURSE THEY
PROBABLY WANT TO GO BACK HOME.
SO TO HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
>> Reporter: IT'S A SENTIMENT
THAT RESONATES WITH FRANCINE.
>> THIS IS MY HOMHOMELAND.
I GREW UP HERE.
I'M NOT ABOUT TO LET ANYBODY
DRIVE ME AWAY.
>> Reporter: FOR "CBS THIS
MORNING SATURDAY," LILIA
LUCIANO, TOHONO O'ODHAM NATION.
>> THAT'S A TOUGH